قال الرئيس الاوكراني في الاردن ان حكومه
تعمل على رفع معدلات الامداد الكهربائي
بشكل مستمر لكنه اكد صعوبه استعاده
الامداد الكهربائي بالكامل كما كان قبل ما
سماه ارهاب الطاقه الروسيه
يتزامن ذلك مع جدول جديد لانقطاعات
الكهرباء اعلنت عنه الجهات المختصه امس
لمواجهه تراجع الامداد بعد الغارات
الروسيه الاخيره
وامداداتها كما نضيف احجاما اكبر من
التوليد كل يوم تقريبا ولكن لا ينبغي ان
ننسى ويجب ان لا ينسى الجميع ان من
المستحيل الان استعاده نظام الطاقه 100%
كما كان قبل بدايه ارهاب طاقه الروسيه
الوقت مطلوب بهذا السبب يتواصل جدول
الانقطاعات في المدن والمقاطعه
في المقابل قال الرئيس الروسي لازم يفوتن
ان الضربه البنيه التحتيه للطاقه في
اوكرانيا جاء ردا على استهداف الجيش
الاوكراني جسر القرن وخطوط الكهرباء
التابعه لمحطه كورس النوويه وندى بوتين
خلال حفل تكريم عدد من العسكريين والضباط
بموقف الدول الغربيه التي اتهمها بغض
الطرف عما يقوم به الجانب الاوكراني ضد
بلاده
[موسيقى]
الكثير من الضجيج حاليا
الطاقه في اوكرانيا نعم نقوم بفعل ذلك لكن
من بدا اولا من الذي ضرب جسر القرم من
الذي فجر خطوط الكهرباء التابعه لمحطه
كورس النوويه ومن يقوم بقطع المياه قطع
المياه عن المدينه المليونيه يرقى الى حد
العباده الجماعيه لم يتفوه احد بكلمه
واحده عن ذلك تاتي كامل لكن بمجرد ان
يتحرك وانا فعل شيئا ما يقيمون الدنيا ولا
يقعدوناها في كل ارجاء العالم هذا لن
يمنعنا عن استكمال مهامنا القتاليه